Whether you're 16 or 40 coming out is never easy
There's never a right time to come out as the only perfect time is when you feel safe and comfortable with your own self
Have you figured out that you're a part of the LGBTQ community, but you're not sure how to tell people about it
Here are 8 things. You need to know before coming out of the closet
It doesn't have to be perfect
It's okay to feel anxious
it's perfectly normal to feel nerves or even anxiety when you're thinking about coming out if
The thought of making the announcement itself is what scares you just remember that coming out doesn't have to be a grand event
Some people may feel empowered by coming out parties and Facebook posts, but it can be as intimate as you need it to be
You don't have to do it alone
Coming out doesn't have to be something you have to handle on your own
It's perfectly okay to have a friend or a loved one someone you've already come out to to accompany you in?
Situations that may make you especially anxious this can include telling your parents
extended family or even a group of friends
Choose the right time
When coming out to close friends and family for the first time it helps to have their undivided attention
Before bringing up something so important
It's not the best idea to come out during major events
Like weddings or baby showers or while the person you're talking to has their minds occupied with other activities
It's also probably not a great idea to bring home a brand new partner to shock your parents with
Coming out can be an emotional time for every party involved
So it's important to give the person you're talking to attention and private time to help them internalize what you're telling them
Before we continue we'd like to thank our partner TUSI cosmetics for sponsoring this video
TUSI cosmetics planes her advocacy for the
LGBTQ community and her passion for makeup to create a line of cosmetic products that shows your inner mermaid
Just like Ariel The Little Mermaid wanted her voice to be heard
a lot of people going through transition have been made fun of or been told that they aren't real when
in the end
Arielle made a sacrifice to make her dreams come true. You should never be judged for who you are or who you want to become
Check out the link below for more information
Don't put yourself at risk
There are situations in which coming-out can mean jeopardizing your own safety
Remember your safety must always come first if you fear that coming out to someone could harm you in any way
Socially or even physically then don't do it
Unfortunately, there are people that may not be accepting of your coming out
but that doesn't mean that you have to live the rest of your life in the closet
If being openly
LGBTQ at home is not a safe option for you or even if you feel ostracized or shamed where you live
It's important to look for support and comfort elsewhere
Search for any LGBTQ friendly community programs or alliances near you or speak to a counselor to discuss your possible options
Throw away your expectations
People's first reactions may not be the ones you wanted or expected
This is a big part of your life that you're opening them up to and everyone reacts differently to news this big
Some people might be completely shocked while others may need some time alone to digest the information
Others may have already seen some clues that you were LGBTQ and may tell you that they had a feeling
Some people may treat the topic very casually as if it was just some cool thing about you that they didn't know
whatever their response try not to judge them and be patient with how they handle your news
A true family bond can't be broken by sexuality. Don't be so hard on your parents
Some parents know their children are queer before they themselves do
But other parents may have a different life for their children planned out in their heads in their minds
You're going to marry a cisgendered person of the opposite sex. You're gonna have children naturally
You would never know the hatefulness and fear of homophobia or transphobia
While the world still has a long way to go in the Equality Department. Your parents need help to understand that you are
Who you've always been and your life for the most part doesn't have to change
Be open with them explain your feelings to them don't be upset if they react with sadness or disappointment
Sometimes we get caught up in thinking that it's everyone else's job to try to see things our way, but your parents aren't perfect
They need help understanding to
Prepare yourself for questions
Be open to questions. Know that the people you came out to may ask questions lots and lots of questions
Sometimes they may not always feel appropriate. In fact, they might feel a tad invasive
But they're just curious. They're just trying to gain an understanding of your newly proclaimed identity
Note that while it's important to be open and willing to educate those close to you about yourself
You also don't have to feel like you need to explain everything
There are some things you would rather keep private. There are others. We don't always know the answer to. Just be patient
Coming out never ends
Heterosexual people don't have to walk into a room and shout. Hey, I'm straight and you shouldn't have to either
We often don't understand how much our sexual and gender identities play into our everyday lives until we realize we're queer
Do you talk about your girlfriend? When all the other girls in the room are discussing funny things that their boyfriend said?
Whether you decide to disclose your LGBTQ identity or not is up to you and your comfort level
It might always be a little nerve-racking to let people find out that you're LGBTQ, but it gets easier every time
Coming out can be daunting and sometimes it feels like there are a hundred reasons why we just shouldn't do it at all
But once you're ready, there are a thousand reasons, why coming out can be amazing
Coming out is never easy. The most important part is being confident and true to yourself
Do you have any coming-out advice that you'd like to give? Let your fellow psych2go readers know in the comment section down below
National Coming Out Day is October 11th, and it's been around since 1988
Thanks for watching. And also don't forget to check out our sponsor in the description down below www.tusicometics.com
You